muy bien dejamos el vídeo pasado en la
recta final de este cálculo desordenado
que tenemos que resolver para tratar de
encontrar la pendiente y también ser
capaces de ver cómo va a comportarse e
interceptar y es que donde teníamos que
tomar la raíz cuadrada de esto
eventualmente hay que factorizar
entonces hay que ser optimistas y veamos
cómo podemos simplificar esto de una
forma razonable así que veamos este
factor de 104 al cuadrado será útil para
sacar varios factores entonces 104-104
va a ser lo mismo que si tenemos cuatro
veces 26 pues cuatro veces 25 nos da 100
y estamos buscando el 104 entonces está
perfecto que sea cuatro veces 26 y nos
da el 104 a su vez el 26 es lo mismo que
si tenemos dos veces 13 y al hacer toda
esta operación nos tiene que arrojar el
104 que es 4 por 2 por 13 y ahorita no
nos vamos a fijar en la raíz cuadrada
pero hay que recordar que era 104 al
cuadrado entonces voy a multiplicar dos
veces cada término para que nos arroje
este de aquí y aquí estos ya estarían el
104 al cuadrado entonces también tenemos
las cuatro veces ahora hay que sacar
factores de 495 entonces 495 va a ser lo
mismo que cinco veces cinco por por cien
es 500 entonces va a ser lo mismo aquí
que tengamos 5 por 99 para que nos
arroje 495 y a su vez el 99 es lo mismo
que 9 por 11 entonces el 495 5 veces 9
por 11 ahora hay que encontrar un factor
para 400 el cual es un poco más sencillo
el cual podemos que sea lo mismo que 4
veces cuatro veces les parece 10 por 10
para que sea como el 4 veces y en 400 y
es por de ese 100 entonces ahora tenemos
todo esto por lo cual podemos ir
encontrando en esta en esta suma unos
factores que podamos sacar del radical
entonces aquí tenemos cuatro por cuatro
y en este lado de la suma también
tenemos cuatro por cuatro por lo que lo
podemos sacar o factorizar de dicha raíz
a hacer su raíz que sería la raíz de 16
y luego la raíz de todo esto pero hay
que poner atención porque de hecho vamos
a hacer algunas cuentas importantes para
qué pues pues tenemos dos por dos es
cuatro y luego trece por trece al hacer
la operación del 13 por 13 esto va a
arrojar los 169 entonces sería 169 por 4
lo voy a hacer fuera de la raíz para que
no empecemos a tener sucio el espacio de
trabajo y se entiendan todas las cuentas
entonces tenemos 169 por 4 que es esto
que estoy señalando acá entonces al
hacer la operación 9 por 4 es 36
llevamos 36 por 4 es 24 y 3 daría 27
entonces llevamos 24 por 14 son entonces
676 de este lado por lo que serían 676
de este resultado 676 y ahora veamos que
del otro lado de la suma tenemos cinco
veces 9 por 11 y al hacer esta operación
la voy a hacer tantito fuera de la de la
raíz será 5 por 9 por 11 es 495 y luego
10 por 10 100 entonces será
495% esto va a ser más
495 y le agregamos simplemente los dos
ceros del 100 lo cual nos va a arrojar
un resultado de 49.500 por lo que esto
lo voy a realizar con calma creo que
tenemos que realizar demasiadas cuentas
pero bueno primeramente tenemos la raíz
de 16 que va a ser 4 por la raíz
cuadrada de todo esto que es realmente
interesante y un tanto complicado va a
ser encontrar los factores a 676 más
49.500 que esta suma me va a dar 50.000
déjame ver 50 mil
176 entonces pues eso nos queda realizar
la suma y hay que hacer la raíz cuadrada
nada más y para realizarla hay que
descomponer este valor el valor de 50
mil 176 y veamos que este valor citó es
divisible será divisible entre 4 bueno
si tú ya tienes práctica sobre todo este
de la descomposición pues te va a ser un
poco más fácil si no pues hay que
hacerlo paso por paso entonces pero
bueno veamos que esto es divisible entre
4 entonces
50 mil 176 entre 4
se cabe en el 4 cabe 12 veces en 50 esto
da 48 menos 2 bajamos el 1 aquí cabe 5
veces nos resta 1 bajamos el 10 y nos
bajamos el c el 7 entonces aquí cada 4
veces nos resta 1 y bajamos el 6
finalmente aquí es 4 entonces vemos que
es 4 veces
12 mil 544 y a su vez de 12 mil 544
veamos que es divisible entre 4 entonces
12 mil 544 entre 4 también voy a notarlo
por acá como te digo si tú ya tienes una
facilidad de impresionante al realizar
este tipo de divisiones pues que mejor
si no estamos practicando muchísima
aritmética entonces cuatro veces tres es
12 aquí nuestro está 0 5 5 por 5 4 por
unos 4 restamos esto nos va a arrojar 24
cada vez seis veces en fin esto sería
cuatro veces el
3.136 y una vez más este es difícil de
entre 4 también hay que volver a
realizar todo todo esto al parecer creo
que me va a terminar saliendo puro 16
pero bueno hay que hacer las cuentas
porque no me quiero equivocar hemos
avanzado demasiado el problema como para
ahorita equivocarme y por no hacer una
cuenta bien entonces al realizar estas
operaciones pero a ustedes concentrando
nos queda cuatro veces de
784 y bueno a su vez también en 784 es
divisible entre 4 al hacer está esta
división queda 4 por una 4 nos restan 3
38 49 por 4 es 36 nos sobran 2 tal vez
seis veces entonces esto es cuatro veces
196 como te digo debes casi puro 4 voy a
hacer ahora la siguiente que a su vez
hay que descomponer también el 196
entonces creo que creo que este es
divisible entre 16 me me voy a aventar a
realizar una vez la división entre 16
veces 190 y 6 no veamos no esto no me va
a dejar un residuo cero mejor lo hacemos
con 4 para que no haya pierde entonces
sería la raíz de digo la división de 196
entre 4 esto nos da 4 veces esto 36
entonces tenemos 49 4 veces 49 y bueno
aquí ya tenemos un número más tangible
si te das cuenta tenemos cinco veces el
4 y este quinto lo podemos tomar para
sacarlo como factor y bueno espero que
al final de todas estas divisiones y
descomposición es ya se hace un experto
y bueno entonces como decíamos este
factor del 4 lo que podríamos hacer con
él es que tenemos cinco veces el 4
entonces ya como 4 a la quinta esto nos
va a dar 1024 y al sacar a sacarlo de la
raíz esto nos arrojaría el 32 entonces
sería 4 que teníamos afuera por 32 por
la raíz de 49 que la raíz de 49 como
sabemos es 7 entonces aquí ya tenemos un
número muy accesible entonces ahora
realizar esta operación tenemos que ser
a 32 por 4 es 4 por 2 8 4 por 3 12 128 y
a su vez esto multiplicado por 7 7 por 8
7 por 8 va a poner de de otro color 7
por 8 56 entonces llevamos 5 7 por 2 es
14 y 5 19 por lo que entonces llevamos
una 7 por 17 y 18 de verdad mi cerebro
está frito ya no no puedo realizarlo
ahorita esto tan rápido verdad tanta
cuenta no no me gusta realizar no estoy
tan rápido y bueno este resultado sería
el de esto que tenemos aquí de esta
operación de aquí esto es igual a 896
ahora si te das cuenta tenemos que es
más o menos y vamos a tomar el positivo
dado que queremos tener una pendiente
positiva entonces m cuadrada va a ser
igual a menos 104 si menos 104 que
tenemos aquí más más
896 que es lo que tenemos de toda esta
operación de la raíz entonces si lo
ponemos por acá sería 700 92 y todo esto
a su vez va a estar dividido entre el
990 aquí que tenemos de la parte del 2
por a de abajo y bueno si observamos
bien estos creo que son son divisibles
entre 9 para irlo reduciendo hay que
quitando tantos valores entonces m
cuadrada va a ser igual voy a quitar
esta parte de mi cuenta de aquí para
tener más espacio y literalmente este es
el vídeo de aritmética prácticamente
pero de verdad no quisiera cometer un
error para lograr obtener una respuesta
correcta me dolería después de todo lo
que hemos avanzado con estos vídeos así
que esperemos no tener ningún ningún
error entonces 9 392 entre 9 vamos a
tener que esto va a ser igual a 88 y 990
entre 9 esto es igual a 110 y a su vez
estos son divisibles si observas entre
11 entonces esto va a ser 8 y aquí vamos
a tener nada más y nada menos que 10 no
10 por 11 110 y a su vez esto es igual a
4 quinto si por fin estamos obteniendo
lo que queríamos de verdad es increíble
que todo esté de toda esta cuenta se
reduzca a cuatro quintos y bueno m
cuadrada es igual a cuatro quintos pero
a su vez podemos acá raíz de ambas
partes entonces tendríamos dos sobre la
raíz de cinco así que esta es nuestra
pendiente la de la pendiente de nuestra
línea recta ahora sí vamos a regresar a
esta ecuación y esperemos que sea más
simple encontrar ahora la aie que va a
interceptar simplemente la y entonces
recordemos que m es igual a 2 sobre la
raíz de 5 y b era igual a 9 m cuadrada
menos 4 donde habita m cuadrada es igual
a 4 quintos a sustituirla y bueno para
hacer esta operación ocupó espacio pero
pero no yo iba a quitar todo pero no va
a decir que más adelante ocupe algunas
de estas ecuaciones entonces mejor lo
resuelvo aquí al lado entonces 9 x 4 es
36 puntos menos 5 x 4 es 20 sobre 5 ésta
con su raíz esto es 16 56 36 quintos 20
es igual a 16 quintos la raíz de de de
16 es 4 entonces esto nos queda 4 sobre
la raíz de 5 y finalmente
prácticamente hemos acabado ya solamente
nos falta sustituir estos valores en
nuestra ecuación de la aie y esto sería
igual a 2 sobre la raíz de 5 por x + 4
sobre la raíz de 5 y ahora podríamos
simplificar esto despejando un tanto la
ecuación entonces si paso está ambas
partes tienen la raíz de 5 si paso la
raíz de 5 porque esto nos queda igual a
2 x + 4
ahora esto al pasar del otro lado sería
menos 2 x más sin la raíz de 5 porque
menos 4 y todo esto sería igual a 0 y si
vamos ahora a nuestras opciones de
posibles respuestas y vemos que es esta
parte de aquí solo que nos falta
multiplicar por un signo negativo de
verdad este es el vídeo con mayor
cantidad de cuentas que he hecho creo
que en toda mi vida y bueno esto ya nos
queda 2 x menos la raíz de 5 más 4 igual
a 0 y vemos que dicha respuesta que
tanto buscamos es la respuesta b y lo
hemos hecho lo hemos logrado